[Musik]
[Applaus]
angebliche hightech präzision geschosse
und lenkraketen mit einer blindgänger
quote von 60 prozent kampfjets die nicht
schießen können weil sie keine munition
haben panzer die zu hunderten zur
todesfalle für ihre eigene mannschaft
werden fortgeschrittene waffensysteme
die auf fahrzeuge mit riesigen reifen
aus der sowjetzeit montiert sind und
granatwerfer die beim abschuss nicht den
gegner zur festen sondern die eigene
mannschaft sofern sich diese nicht
sowieso schon wegen der abgelaufenen und
verfolgten lebensmittel mit denen sie
die ganze zeit gefüttert wird in
bauchkrämpfen findet man könnte meinen
dies sei die handlung einer komödie im
stile von hot shots aber in wirklichkeit
geht es um die russische invasion in der
ukraine und es ist nur ein winzig
kleiner ausschnitt aus dem unglaublich
großen fast schon unwirklich scheinende
haufen von fa cups der russischen armee
in diesem krieg jahre lang dachten viele
russland hätte eine rüstungsindustrie
von weltrang klar die russische
wirtschaft insgesamt ist nichts womit
man irgendwie herum bossen könnte das
land ist kaum in der lage produkte mit
hoher wertschöpfung wie autos handys
oder software auf konkurrenzfähigen
niveau zu exportieren aber die
rüstungsindustrie war doch immer dass
juden in der russlands krone
um euch eine vorstellung davon zu geben
in russland sind zwischen 2,5 und 3
millionen menschen in der
reifenproduktion beschäftigt das sind
ganze 20 prozent der
industriearbeitsplätze des landes keine
andere volkswirtschaft kommt auch eine
so große abhängigkeit von der
rüstungsindustrie heran mit anderen
worten es schien als seien die
waffenfabriken ende russland die
ausnahme welche die regel bestätigt die
einzige branche des verarbeitenden
gewerbes die wirklich funktionierte
dieses bild hat und putin jedes jahr bei
den militärparaden gezeichnet am ende
eines jeden jahres feiert russland den
sieg im zweiten weltkrieg oder die man
dort sagt im großen vaterländischen
krieg der rote platz in moskau fühlt
sich mit menschen welche die neuesten
waffen der armee sehen wollen die
unglaublich tollen zu 34 kampfjets
vorführung kunststücke moderner armada
panzer rollen durch die straßen und die
ganze welt erschaudert ein putin seine
atombomben vor dem kreml spazieren fährt
selbst viele gestandene experten im
westen haben sich von dieser perfekten
show blenden lassen und dachten groß
land hätte die militärische stärke um
die ukraine innerhalb von wenigen tagen
zu besiegen aber die ware über eine
armee der ultimative test militärische
macht eines landes zeigt sich nicht in
einer parade einzig und allein im krieg
und mit der invasion in die ukraine
erleben werde dass jede zustände die in
der russischen wirtschaft zur norm
geworden sind auch für die
rüstungsindustrie gelten die
wunschträume vieler russischer
nationalisten und ihrer sympathisanten
sind auf die härteste aller realitäten
getroffen und die ironie daran sie haben
es selbst so gewollt die usa schätzen
die ausfallrate einiger russischer
raketen auf bis zu 60 prozent im ersten
video unserer trilogie über das
russische militär im krieg welches dir
vor einer woche veröffentlicht haben
ging es um die struktur der armee heute
knüpfen wir uns den zweiten kriegs
entscheidenden bereich vor ihre
bewaffnung und ausrüstung im nächsten
werde es dann direkt um die
konfrontation mit der armee der ukraine
gehen vergesst also bitte nicht das abo
und auch nicht das glöckchen denn selbst
falls ihr schon ein abo habt solltet ihr
das glücken aktivieren wenn das abo
alleine ignorierte youtube algorithmus
mittlerweile weitgehend wenn er euch
neue videos vorschlägt und ihr wollt
auch keines unserer spannenden videos
verpassen oder der liegewiese politik
zuschauer nach allem was russland
während seines kriegs in der keine
vorgeführt hat könnte das fazit nicht
klarer sein die russische
bleibt weit hinter den erwartungen vor
allem jeden hype zurück den sie jahre
land ausgelöst hatte so weit dass das
schiere ausmaß des versagens selbst uns
überrascht hat und das obwohl er bereits
vor anderthalb jahren eklatante defizite
bei der modernisierung der russischen
armee aufgezeigt haben welche putin 2008
zu seiner obersten priorität gemacht
hatte das video hierzu verlinke ich euch
natürlich in der beschreibung holt das
heutige video ist sozusagen eine
abdeckung damaligen etwas worum uns
viele zuschauer gebeten haben vergesst
bitte nicht dass über ein land sprechen
das hat einigen jahren mehr als fünf
prozent seines bruttoinlandsprodukts für
verteidigung ausgibt zum vergleich
deutschland hat angekündigt dass es zwei
prozent ausgeben wird und das erscheint
ein historische kraftanstrengung zu sein
mit anderen worten russland hat als alle
verfügbaren ressourcen in die
verbesserung seiner fassung gesteckt
zumindest jene welche die organischen um
generäle nicht unbedingt zu ihren
luxuriösen lebensstil benötigten gut es
stimmt zwar dass niemand erwartet hatte
dass das russische arsenal dass der
vereinigten staaten übertreffen würde
aber im vergleich zu anderen ländern vor
allem der ukraine china russland eine
militärische supermacht zu sein
[Musik]
wir sehen nun jedoch dass die ergebnisse
der rüstung und militär reformen putins
eine echte katastrophe sowohl für das
land als auch seine patient kirche armee
darstellen man könnte sagen russland
hatten milliarden von rubel in die
herstellung von waffen investiert die
sich nun entweder als vollkommener short
herausgestellt haben oder so dämlich zum
einsatz kam dass sie als solcher endeten
oder noch besser massenhaft der ukraine
in die hände fiel tatsächlich hat sich
russland während der letzten zwei monate
als der größte wenn auch unfreiwillige
waffenlieferant der ukraine entpuppt
zumindest was einige waffengattungen die
panzer angeht dann wissen verfügt die
ukraine hatte sogar über mehr panzer und
gepanzerte fahrzeuge als vor dem krieg
selbst man lieferungen aus den besten
herausrechnet und die frage ist
natürlich warum eigentlich was in aller
welt ist in russlands militär industrie
schief gelaufen wie konnte es nur so
weit kommen warum unterhält russland
obwohl so viel geld investiert werden so
veraltetes arsenal heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten und zwar
erstmals in einem kurzen blick in die
geschichte denn wie so oft wird dort die
ursachen der ganzen misere
[Musik]
vom kommunismus in den merkantilen
welches ist das berühmteste sturmgewehre
welt ganz genau die ak-47 besser bekannt
als die kalaschnikow wie ihr
wahrscheinlich alle wisst ist die
kalaschnikow ein städtisches fabrikat
weil er solche methode der
rüstungsindustrie wird und viele von
euch denken dass die sowjetunion eine
waffenindustrie von weltklasse hatte
doch die realität sah ganz anders aus
fast jede waffe aus dem sowjetischen
arsenal es sich in einem mini
zusammenfassen es gibt einen großen
unterschied zwischen erwartung und
wirklichkeit
[Musik]
die sowjetische rüstungsindustrie wurde
von unrentablen staatsbetrieben
veralteten fabrik und vor allem von viel
korruption nominiert natürlich gibt es
korruption überall in der
rüstungsindustrie rund um den erdball in
den vereinigten staaten gibt es eine
enge allianz zwischen der regierung und
privaten unternehmen den militärisch
industriellen komplex und wir haben auch
visuell politik schon mehrfach darüber
gesprochen auch über die probleme ein
beispiel ist die f35 washington musste
seine flotte erneuern deswegen haben sie
eine ausschreibung durchgeführt bei der
mehrere private unternehmen angebote
abgaben in diesem fall waren die
hauptkandidaten boeing und lockheed
martin am ende gewann lok in den
wettbewerb oder hielt einen auftrag im
wert von mehreren milliarden dollar
natürlich hat sich gezeigt dass dieses
system seine probleme hat private
unternehmen wollen ihren gewinn
maximieren
sie locken ihre auftraggeber in
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse und
beschäftigen heer von lobbyisten und
politiker beamte und militärs zu
beeinflussen das ergebnis sind
wettbewerbsverzerrungen und gigantische
budgetüberschreitungen wie zb im fall
der f-35 wir sprechen hier von mehr als
400 milliarden dollar die aus der tasche
des steuerzahlers gelockt wurden um den
gewinn eines privatunternehmens zu
steigern man kann also und muss viele
aspekte an diesem system kritisieren
aber trotz all seine probleme hat das
amerikanische system die beteiligten
unternehmen immerhin in die lage
versetzt die modernsten waffen der welt
zu entwickeln und vor allem gegen
ausreichenden stückzahlen zu produzieren
irgendwie hat er jahrzehntelang
wettbewerb zwischen den unternehmen doch
einigermaßen funktioniert der sport
kommunismus basiert jedoch auf der
gegenteiligen idee
die gesamte wirtschaft hängt vom staat
und eine zentralen planung ab die
rüstungsindustrie beruhte daher auf
staatlichen monopolen und ja gerade in
der rüstung gab es eine große ausnahme
das militär wollte im gegensatz zu ivan
normal genossen schon eine gewisse wahl
haben und beauftragte daher mehrere
ingenieur und designbüros parallel mit
der entwicklung des selben auftrags mit
hilfe dieses wettbewerbs bekamen sie
recht gut entwürfe und prototypen in die
durchaus mit ihren westlichen fotos
mithalten konnten das problem war jedoch
dass diese konkurrenz mechanismen auf
die entwicklungsphase begrenzt waren in
der produktion kam wieder die zentrale
planung zum einsatz es gab zwar eine
menge und dann zum beispiel
produktionsausfälle abfangen zu können
wenn im kriegsfall werke im westteil des
landes verloren gehen aber auch diese
beruhten auf klassischer planwirtschaft
nun ja die ergebnisse waren und sind für
alle sichtbar ronald reagan wett
richtete die sowjetunion an die wand und
das fertige russland hat ist noch nicht
einmal fertig gebracht und der nervenden
ausreichender stückzahl und qualität zu
produzieren um die ukraine militärisch
dominieren zu können von der nato mal
ganz zu schweigen galt russland vor den
krieg mit der ukraine vielen noch als
zweitgrößte militärmacht auf dem
planeten stellt sich nun die frage ob es
überhaupt noch zur top ten zu zählen ist
aber ich weiß was es denkt mag die
sowjetunion ist vor 30 jahren
verschwunden russland hat den
kommunismus aufgegeben den kapitalismus
eingeführt und niemand der bei verstand
ist würde sagen dass wladimir putin ein
eingefleischter kommunist sei nun ja das
alles stimmt aber nur zum teil ja seit
jahrzehnten befindet sich russland in
ein system das nur noch wenig mit der
bolschewistischen revolution zu tun hat
aber es hat den kapitalismus mit freier
oder soziale marktwirtschaft nie
angenommen wir haben vor kurzem ein
video darüber gedreht das auslands war
vor jahrzehnten den kommunismus aufgabe
aber noch immer eine starke
zentralisierte wirtschaftsstruktur
aufweist die er einem von klicken
gesteuerten merkantilismus entspricht
der staat was auch immer das an russland
bedeutet spielt immer noch eine zentrale
rolle in allen branchen inklusive der
rüstungsindustrie warum aber haben die
russen ihre lektion aus der niederlage
im kalten krieg nicht lernen wollen
rückschläge können doch auch in chance
in sich bergen sein strategie zu
überdenken und es in zukunft besser zu
machen nun bei näherer betrachtung
wollten sie dies durchaus putin ließ
nach der blamage in georgien eine
detaillierte analyse durchführen und
baute auf ihren ergebnissen eine
armeereform auf die russen wollten das
so lernen und ihre rüstungsindustrie
grundlegend modernisieren das problem
war nur sie zogen die falschen schlüsse
welche genau nun das sehen wir uns jetzt
sofort an
die denkweise der stilo wiki
[Musik]
ich weiß dass viele von euch denken wenn
ihr wollt dass eure unternehmen
wettbewerbsfähig sind ist es das beste
sie zu privatisieren damit sie
miteinander konkurrieren können nicht
wahr so würde es zumindest die logik der
freien marktwirtschaft diktieren aber
putins russland funktioniert nach einer
ganz anderen logik laut wladimir putin
war das problem des kommunismus nicht
die zentralisierte wirtschaft sondern
eine wirtschaft die auf ideologischen
prinzipien basiert er meinte wenn man
die effizienz des systems verbessern
will reicht es aus die manager
auszutauschen statt parteigenossen mit
bestnoten fächern marxismus leninismus
sollten technokraten an die spitze
rücken natürlich technokraten die im
schosse des kgb geschmiedet wurden um
die eine eigene pragmatischen mentalität
haben völlig frei von der romantik des
kommunismus oder einer anderen ideologie
dieser art von mensch hat einen namen
kilo wiegt wie lautet also putins formel
um seine militärindustrie fit fürs
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert zu machen
ganz einfach er installierte seines
thilo wiki einfach in alle
führungspositionen so entstand 2007
rostek ein konglomerat ein unternehmen
welches als große schirm gesellschaft
der russischen verteidigung dienen
sollte unter diesem dach befinden sich
mehr als 700 rüstungsunternehmen die
sich allesamt in staatsbesitz befinden
[Musik]
der gedanke dahinter in den unternehmen
zusammenfassen können viele redundanzen
vermieden werden alles nach dem
technokratischen hyper pragmatischen
kriterien und wer ist der ceo von
rostekhnologii
sergei jamals oft ein ehemaliger kollege
von wladimir putin beide haben zusammen
in den dresdner kgb büros gearbeitet mit
anderen worten ein 10 uwg wie aus dem
lehrbuch und ihr werdet euch fragen ob
rostek ist wirklich geschafft hat die
kosten zu senken und effizienter zu
werden nun ja durchaus und einen
eindruck zu verschaffen 2008 hatten alle
unternehmen unter dem dach von rostock
zusammen fast 800.000 beschäftigte und
im jahr 2010 waren es nur noch 440.000
seit seiner gründung hat rostet nicht
aufgehört alle arten von
rüstungsunternehmen zu absorbieren
die unternehmensführung hat sogar
zugelassen dass privates kapital in
einige der grössten russischen
rüstungsunternehmen einsteigt als
prominentes beispiel sei der hersteller
der legendären ak-47 genannt sagte 74%
des konzerns kalaschnikow befinden sich
in privater hand die massive expansion
von der auszeit brachte jedoch ein
gravierendes problem mit sich
durch die übernahme von immer mehr
unternehmen hat rosberg am ende noch
mehr monopole konsolidiert und das führt
dazu ganz ganz die ein problem haben wir
mit einem klassischen beispiel an
kampfjets die vereinigten staaten
arbeiten den vier großen hersteller
zusammen boeing lockheed martin racing
und airbus ja airbus ist ein
europäisches unternehmen aber es hat
auch verträge mit dem pentagon im falle
russlands werden aber praktisch alle
kampfjets von ein und demselben
unternehmen hergestellt
das natürlich unter dem dach von rostek
angesiedelt ist aber erreicht es denn
wirklich aus eines silowiki an der
spitze eines monopol herstellers zu
setzen um diesen wettbewerbsfähiger zu
machen nun urteil selbst am besten
anhand eines weiteren großen russischen
rüstungsunternehmens almazán teil dieser
konzern ist nicht von ass.tec abhängig
sondern befindet sich direkt im besitz
des russischen finanzministeriums er
beschäftigt 100.000 menschen macht ca 7
milliarden euro umsatz im jahr und sein
geschäftsführer ist wer hätte es gedacht
ein weiteres kilo wiegt in diesem fall
handelt es schon viktor iwanow seines
zeichens ebenfalls ehemaliger kgb agent
zu alma suntech gehört unter anderem mpu
lovato rund ihr fragt euch leicht warum
wir uns gerade für diese firma
interessieren nun sie stellt so gut wie
alle russischen präzisions raketen her
ja genau die raketen über die wir am
anfang dieses videos gesprochen haben
und die sich bei der invasion in der
krise als fehleranfällig erwiesen haben
nun die wahrheit ist dass es sich im
grunde bei all dem um keine große
überraschung handelt eine vorstellung zu
geben 2017 war mpo novato in der lage in
sechs monaten gerade mal 60 kaliber
raketen zu produzieren und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt sind diese zahlen
lächerlich und wir bedenken dass
russland in nur einem kriegs monat mehr
als 1200 raketen auf ziele in der
ukraine abgeschlossen hat
aber gibt es im gesamten russischen
verteidigungskonzept nicht auch private
unternehmen nun doch die gibt es
erinnert ihr euch zb an die abgelaufenen
konservendosen mit denen die großen ihre
soldaten an der front füttern wollen
lacht ein kartell dass angeblich
milliarden verdient durch die es mit dem
russischen militär
ratet mal von welchem kartell wir
sprechen richtig es handelt sich um ein
netzwerk von catering unternehmen das
jetzt geh niedriger schon gehört der
ganz große überraschung ein persönlicher
erfolg putins ist dieser feiner herr ist
als putins koch bekannt ihm gehören
restaurants & catering unternehmen und
nebenbei noch die zahlen der vagener
gruppe wir haben über ihr schon mal
ausführlich an eine früheren video
gesprochen dass ihr euch gerne nachher
ansehen könnt ich werde es hinter den e-
und in der beschreibung verlinken und
wie alexei navalny um seine mitarbeiter
berichtet haben gelernt istrischen alle
öffentlichen ausschreibungen für die
versorgung der truppe mit essen zu
umgehen und so zum chef caterer der
russischen armee zu werden das ergebnis
navalny sitzt im gefängnis und russische
soldaten müssen es hat dort einen fraß
von krieg gene in sich hineinstopfen
irgendwie habe ich den eindruck dass
fast alle staaten nur noch in einer
disziplin miteinander wetteifern selbst
sabotage aber eine wichtigere frage die
sich viele von euch jetzt sicher stellen
lautet moment mal du hast gesagt dass
die raketenfabrik nur 60 präzisions
raketen in sechs monaten produzieren
kann aber russland hat schon mehr als
1200 raketen verschossen wie ist das
überhaupt möglich woher haben sie denn
überhaupt so viele raketen nun das
werden wir jetzt klären
theorie und praxis
die schlüsselfrage die sich sehr viele
sogar viele experten und militär
analysten die ganze zeit gestellt haben
lautete vor allem wie ist es überhaupt
möglich dass russland nicht in der lage
war die lufthoheit zu erlangen das heißt
warum war die russische luftwaffe nicht
sehe ich die ukrainische flugabwehr zu
zerstören oder zumindest so zu sprechen
so dass sie ohne probleme alle
erdenklichen ziele im land nach eigenem
gutdünken bombardieren kann ich meine
denkt mal darüber nach die ukraine hat
nur 134 kampfjets und die stammen alle
aus der sowjet ära russland verfügt über
fast 1200 kampfflugzeuge von denen 300
einsatzbereit gemacht wurden um die
ukraine anzugreifen und wir reden hier
von modernen kampfjets vergesst nicht
dass russland milliarden in die
modernisierung seines militärs
investiert hat auch in die luftwaffe da
wäre zb die suchoi su 34 ein jagdbomber
der 2008 in dienst gestellt wurde auf
dem papier können diese jagdbomber mit
ihren us porno oder f 15e ohne probleme
konkurrieren man könnte sagen dass sie
zu den besten kampfflugzeugen russlands
gehören das problem ist jedoch dass sie
nicht genug präzisionsmunition zur
verfügung haben das mag lächerlich
klingen aber alle daten deuten darauf
hin dass das land ganz einfach nicht
über ausreichend präzisionsmunition
verfügt um diesen tick vernünftig führen
zu können wir sprechen von solchen mit
intelligenten hightech sondern die nicht
erst beim aufschlag sondern noch in der
luft detonieren sollen so dass ihre
explosion gruppen in
verteidigungsposition auszuschalten
vermag all dies fragt ihr euch sicher
warum es russland ausgerechnet an diesen
typ fortgeschrittene munition mangelt
wenn es doch dauernd mit dingen die
hyperschall waffen herum post
nun schauen wir uns das beispiel luft
luft und luft boden raketen an jeder
dieser raketen die von einem flugzeug
abgefeuert wird hat eine lebensdauer von
10 bis 15 jahren das heißt wenn ja in
den krieg ziehen wollt solltet eure
waffen verträgen besser mit voller
kapazität produzieren aber wie wir
bereits gesehen haben kämpfen die
russischen fabriken mit demselben großen
plänen die damals die sowjetischen den
oft unterschätzten tücken der
massenproduktion um den vertrackten und
tiefen der qualitätssicherung und glaubt
mehr davon weiß ich ein liedchen zu
singen durfte ich mich während meines
berufslebens osttochter ingenieur doch
auch einige jahre dem
qualitätsmanagement produktion eines
führenden deutschen automobilherstellers
bitte nicht zufällig wurde tesla von den
etablierten herstellern jahrelang
belächelt sie wussten genau dass die
herstellung von prototypen oder
kleinerer stückzahl eine ganz andere
herausforderung darstellt als die
skalierung des outputs auf tausende
zehntausende oder hunderttausende von
einheiten jede dieser skalierung stufen
stellt eine eigene welt für sich da und
deswegen erklärte elon musk ii auch
genau dies zu absoluten chefsache bei
tesla deswegen verbrachte er unzählige
tage und nächte vor ort in seinen
fabriken bis alles flutscht tja maskat
erkannt worauf es wirklich ankommt und
so die etablierten konzerne geschlagen
und vielleicht hätte auch putin den
jungen jahren sein zelt in den munitions
fabriken aufschlagen sollen anstatt für
seine fanbase mit nackten oberkörper
beim fischen zu posen das ergebnis sehen
wir jetzt in der ukraine die 32 der
neuesten generation müssen dum munition
verschießen was ein eventuell auch für
nachrichten die diese verantwortlich ist
drei tote bei russischen luftangriff auf
entbindungsklinik überlegt mal ein
angriff auf eine entbindungsklinik ist
nicht nur eine gräueltat es ist auch ein
taktischer fehler das ziel eines
angriffs ist es die gegnerische
verteidigung zu verstören kinder in
einem krankenhaus zu töten ist nicht nur
grausam seine dient auch keinen
strategischen ziel kriegsverbrechen wie
diese führe nur dazu dass der gegner
seine reine noch verschließt und noch
mehr verbündete mobilisieren kann die
noch entschlossener vorgehen damit wir
uns nicht falsch verstehen wollen mit
dem argument der fehlenden präzision
keinerlei russische kriegsverbrechen
entschuldigen oder verharmlosen terror
gegen die zivilbevölkerung ist mit
fester bestandteil russischer
kriegsführung in tschetschenien bis
syrien aber viele zivile opfer sind eben
auch das ergebnis des mangels an
präzisionsmunition dies ist ein
wichtiger bestandteil einer objektiven
analyse die geringe verfügbarkeit ein
präzisions ok bestellt natürlich auch
ein großes problem für die russischen
flugzeuge und hubschrauber selbst da sie
sind gezwungen sehr niedrig zu fliegen
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
ein kampfjet der niedrig fliegt ein sehr
leichtes ziel gerade für den mobile
führer der die russische luftwaffe
verliert die am besten steht über der
ukraine ganz genau russlands flugzeuge
stürzen ab wie die fliegen weil sie
keinen geeigneten munition haben mit der
sie sicher angreifen könnten ihre
piloten sind gezwungen abenteuerliche
manöver zu pflegen die wahrlich
vorsintflutlich wirken so heißt ob sie
mit einer art zeitmaschine aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg ins 21 jahrhundert
katapultiert worden wären dutzendweise
werden russische kampfhubschrauber dabei
gesichtet wie sie ihre raketen blind in
den himmel schießen und die leute fragen
sich ob die piloten verrückt geworden
sein oder sabotage betreiben würden nun
die antwort lautet nein die sind nicht
verrückt aber verdammt verzweifelt sie
haben angst sofort abgeschossen zu
werden wenn sie gemäß ihrer bewaffnung
nah genug an ihre ziele anfliegen denn
sie haben keine raketen die weit genug
fliegen oder ihr ziel selbstständig
finden würden aus diesem grund sind sie
gezwungen dieses irrwitzige manöver zu
fliegen sie fliegen mit hoher
geschwindigkeit heranziehen die nase
start oben und vorn dabei all ihrer
raketen quasi als realistische geschosse
auf meiner parabel bahn ab in der
hoffnung dass wenigstens ein paar von
ihnen ihr ziel treffen und ähnlich
ergeht es auch den kampfjets den russen
die luftüberlegenheit zu verweigern weil
die grundlage des bisherigen
ukrainischen erfolgs dies ermöglicht es
den ukrainischen streitkräfte sich
weitgehend frei zu bewegen und erhöht
gleichzeitig die nervosität bei den
russischen gruppen den ukrainischen
luftangriffen ausgesetzt zu sein dabei
hatten die ukraine eigentlich nie die
lufthoheit für sich zu beanspruchen
die russische luftwaffe ist zu groß und
die russische streitkräfte sind gut
ausgestattet dass sie es trotzdem
geschafft haben basiert auf einer
verkettung glücklicher umstände die
ukrainische streitkräfte gold und
russland tatsächlich daran hindern die
kontrolle über den luftraum zu erlangen
indem sie eine reihe von system
miteinander diniert haben darunter eine
kleine zahl hocheffektive mit starthügel
fortschrittliche luftabwehrsysteme und
vor allem eine große zahl tragbarer
luftabwehrwaffen die stinger raketen als
militärmacht die sich traditionell immer
darauf verlassen hat durch ihre schier
endlose masse an bodentruppen zu siegen
auf diese strategie gar stolz ist haben
die russen nicht nur die bedeutung der
luftüberlegenheit unterschätzt sondern
auch die komplexität sie zu erlangen
anstatt ihrer luftwaffe darauf
auszurichten und auszubilden als
allererstes den himmel so beherrschend
beschränkten sie sich auf eine reine
unterstützungsfunktionen bodentruppen
vielleicht handelt es sich hierbei um
das größte das vielen versäumnisse von
profis auch mehrere form die russische
luftwaffe leidet nach wie vor unter
einer mangelhaften logistik und dem
fehlen einer regelmäßigen und
realistischen ausbildung denn die
autokratische russische kleptokratie
traut den offizieren der unteren und
mittleren ränge wohl auch vor recht
nicht über den weg und lässt daher auch
nicht die kreative und flexible
entscheidungsfindung vor auf die sich
die nato luftstreitkräfte verlassen
können und welche in den letzten jahren
auch die ukraine gelernt haben die
russische luftwaffe kann so zwar
vereinzelt ukrainische stellung
bombardieren aufgrund ungeeigneter
munition sind diese einsätze jedoch
hochgradig riskant und er von der sorte
schnell rein und wieder raus eine
kontinuierliche lufthoheit sieht anders
aus und da die ukraine auf diese weise
die mobilität ihrer streitkräfte
aufrecht erhalten haben konnten sie die
städte in festungen und straßensperren
verwandeln was die russische logistik
und kommunikation erheblich erschwert
vor diesem video haben einige zuschauer
in den kommentaren gesagt dass sie
einfach nicht verstehen können warum die
russen vor dem einfall mit ihrer land
armee nicht erst mal alle
verteidigungsstellungen und die
infrastruktur der ukraine zeitpunkt
haben so wie zb die amerikaner im irak
krieg nun ich glaube jetzt habt ihr die
antwort sie konnten es einfach nicht aus
den hier genannten gründen
[Musik]
und wir könnten mit diesen beispielen
ewig weitermachen denn eine ähnliche
verkettung von je nach sicht glücklichen
oder unglücklichen umständen wurden auch
den panzertruppen russland zum
verhängnis der aggressor hatte in diesem
krieg bereits mehr als 1100 von safran
wen er zum zeitpunkt des drehs dieses
videos ablaufenden schlacht um den don
was verliert die russische armee dabei
im schnitt 30 panzer pro tag damit ihr
euch eine vorstellung von der intensität
dieser gefechte und verluste machen
könnte diese zahlen entsprechen etwa den
verlusten der wehrmacht während der
größten landschlacht der weltgeschichte
der schlacht um kurs während des so
genannten unternehmens zitadelle der
letzten deutschen großoffensive im krieg
in die sowjetunion im jahr 1943
vereinzelte gruppen von tiger fans an
drachen durch den neuen panzer waren
weniger erfolgreich
überall selbst beginnen die sowjetische
infanterie nach der unterschied zu
damals besteht jedoch darin dass die
deutschen überproportional viele ältere
panzer wie den panzer kampfwagen 3
verloren haben so dass sie mit hilfe der
immer noch gut laufen rüstungsproduktion
diese lücken gut mit neun moderneren
panzern die dem canter aufhören konnten
so waren die nazis trotz ihrer
gigantischen verluste in der lage dem
krieg noch weitere zwei jahre
fortzuführen und nun spulen wir die zeit
bis in die gegenwart vor im jahr 2022
gibt es in russland nur noch einen
einzigen panzerhersteller oral war und
sah wird dieser gehört ebenfalls zur ost
beschäftigt 30.000 mitarbeiter und macht
normalerweise zwei milliarden dollar
umsatz bei einem maximalen produktions
auspuff von 200 bis 400 gramm pro jahr
die russische armee verbrennt als
momentan alle zehn tage eine komplette
jahresproduktion an konzern das heißt
allein um die bisherigen verluste wieder
aufzufüllen müsste ural war gut vier
jahre lang volle pulle produzieren und
das allergrößte problem ist dass sie
dies gar nicht mehr können berichten
zufolge mussten sie die produktion darf
vollständig stoppen da aufgrund
göttlichen lobby sanktionen oder ein
gestörter lieferketten akuter mangel
wichtigen teilen besteht die nur von
ausländischen herstellern geliefert
werden können so und dieses problem
betrifft natürlich nicht nur platz
sondern so gut wie jede russische waffen
die auch nur ein bisschen
fortgeschrittene ist als das zeug aus
den 1980 er jahren
[Applaus]
abgeschossene russische drohnen waren
voller westlicher beziehungsweise
japanische koreanische und
taiwanesischer komponenten wie zb für
fotokameras gedacht waren russland kann
auch keine intelligenten sensoren
herstellen weil sie für lenkraketen und
die flughöhen abhängige zündung von
artilleriegranaten benötigt werden man
könnte diese aufzählung endlos
weiterführen und sie würde am ende immer
nur zu keinem einzigen ergebnis führen
die russische armee in ausreichender
stückzahl nur über dumme low tech waffen
und munition und muss damit gegen
ukraine kämpfen die von der nato immer
mehr high tech system ausgerüstet werden
mittlerweile ist dieses thema sogar in
die propaganda talkshows des russischen
staatsfernsehens durchgedrungen aber
auch die diskussion dort zeigt dass die
russen wirklich null dazugelernt haben
so wurde dort von experten tatsächlich
die totale umstellung der kompletten
russischen wirtschaft auf eine zentral
gelenkte kriegswirtschaft im rahmen
einer generalmobilmachung vorgeschlagen
was für eine grandiose idee
produktionsanlagen sowie fehlende
komponente zu schaffen könnte jahre
dauern was angesichts des tempos in
denen das russische arsenal in der
ukraine dezimiert wird vollkommen
irrsinn ist genauso wie die idee einer
generalmobilmachung denn die mit low
tech equipment ausgestattet und
reservisten hätten keinerlei chance
gegen die mit nato waffen frisch
belieferten ukraine wie will außerdem
eine armee die schon die logistik für
knapp 200.000 mann nicht hinbekommt
diese für hunderttausende von
reservisten bewerkstelligen nein eine
generalmobilmachung der für die russen
nichts anderes als ein gewaltmarsch zur
ukrainischen schlachtbank ein massaker
unvorstellbaren ausmaßes
der offenbarungseid der russischen
rüstungsindustrie stellt jedoch nicht
nur eine katastrophe für russland als
kriegspartei dar sondern auch für dessen
weitere zukunft als waffenexporteur
vergessen wir nicht dass waffen und
rohstoffe die einzigen güter darstellen
mit denen russland noch auf den
weltmarkt punkten kann das versagen
seiner waffen im krieg in der ukraine
ist für seine rüstungsindustrie doch so
etwas wie eine negative werbekampagne
und zwar gigantischen ausmaßes es
handelt sich quasi um die totale
entzauberung eine giftpille export
sanktionen die sich das land was sie
selbst auferlegt hat dem kreml werden
durch die wegbrechenden exporteinnahmen
so auch nach einem möglichen ende des
krieges weitere mittel für die
aufstockung des eigenen personals fiel
bereits während der schlacht und kiew
hat sich gezeigt dass die russische
armee außerdem nicht über die sehr
wichtigen logistischen und koordinativen
kapazitäten verfügt offensiv operation
die in feindlichen gebiet zu
unterstützen sie war einfach nicht in
der lage ihre kampfeinheiten an der
front mit all dem zu versorgen was diese
brauchten und wir sprechen nicht nur
über artillerieunterstützung ist
unterstationen flugabwehr sondern über
vollkommen grundlegenden dinge die essen
treibstoff und munition es war ein
großer fehler die haupt offensive in
vier große achsen aufzuteilen wenn man
keine funktionierende expedition
slawistik hat etwas in dem die
amerikaner absolute experten sind die
russen müssen ihre front truppen jedoch
von logistik basen in russland und
weißrussland aus versorgen und da ist
für front um kiew keine geeigneten
eisenbahnlinien gab waren sie gezwungen
alles auf lastwagen zu laden das problem
da die generäle und silowiki das geld
lieber in funkelnde schaffen und ihre
villen investiert haben verfügt das
gesamte militär gar nicht über genügend
lastwagen um eine so breit angelegte
offensive zu versorgen woher wir das
wissen nun die russin musste sogar weite
teile ihrer tricks logistik mitten in
feindesland mit zivilen lastwagen
durchführen ein sehr ungewöhnliches
vorgehen und dann haben die ukraine ihre
lkw ist natürlich zerstört oder lahm
gelegt wodurch die nachschublinie
vollkommen zusammengebrochen sind sie
waren also nicht mehr in der lage die
fordern einheiten mit den zu versorgen
was diese zum weiterkämpfen und
überleben brauchen und all das erklärt
warum ihre invasion in der ukraine so
merkwürdige bilder wie dieses
hervorgebracht hat
und ich weiß was viele von euch jetzt
denken lassen muss das bitte mal klar
stellen mag wirst du wirklich sagen dass
die russen so doof sind einfach in den
krieg zu ziehen ohne ordentlich
funktionierende logistik sogar ohne
geeignete munition nun das problem ist
dass ein politisches system das seinen
leistungsträgern die falsche anreize
bietet langfristig einfach zum scheitern
verurteilt ist mit bill clintons worten
ist die economy stupid auch wir haben
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen die
russische wirtschaft so konzipiert dass
kein unternehmen der kontrolle putins
und seiner clique entkommen kann doch
bei dieser kontrolle geht es nicht um
qualität sie kann nicht jeder kultur der
korruption entkommen aus welcher sie
selbst sprang denn welches personal
steht putin schließlich zur verfügung
sowohl in der rüstungs wirtschaft als
auch in der armee wer ist bereit seien
dabei zu sein was für ein generalstab
entwirft eine derart miserablen kampagne
wie wir sie gesehen haben nun es muss
ein generalstab sein der hauptsächlich
darauf fixiert ist sich selbst zu
bereichern und nicht wirklich weiß was
er tut da ziehen sie über ein jahr lang
truppen an der grenze zusammen und
schicken dann zur versorgung der
invasion aber nur lastwagen in die
ukraine die kaputt gehen weil sie
einfach zu alt schlecht oder gar nicht
gedacht waren und weil unter den
soldaten nicht genügend ausgebildete
mechaniker waren weil sie die fahrzeuge
vor ort hätten bergen und reparieren
können wir haben unzählige fotos und
videos von dem russischen lkw s gesehen
die am straßenrand liegen den scheinbar
nichts fehlt aber man kann sehen dass
flüssigkeit aus den radkästen austritt
oder dass die motoren ausgefallen sind
das alles bedeutet dass diese lkw
wahrscheinlich monate oder jahre lang
einfach nur irgendein im depot
herumstanden ohne dass jemand auch nur
den motor angelassen oder die dichtungen
ausgetauscht hätte die mangelnde
qualitätskontrolle zieht sich also ganz
natürlich von der russischen
rüstungsindustrie bis in die armee
selbst deswegen ist russland in einer
art rüstung wirtschaftlichen autismus
gefangen und in dieser hinsicht auch
absolut effizient aber wenn es um
kreativität innovation und die
komplexität und qualitätssicherung in
der massenproduktion geht sind diese
logik nicht in der lage ergebnisse zu
erzielen wir sehen also wieder einmal
dass zwischen den erwartungen an die
silowiki und realität ein himmelweiter
unterschied besteht die wahrheit ist
allerdings dass wir es in russland bei
weitem nicht das erste mal mit diesem
phänomen zu tun haben wir könnten hier
unzählige beispiele aufzählen das
smartphone der russischen firma jutta an
der ebenfalls rostek beteiligt war und
über das der damalige personalchef sagte
es würde apple bereits große sorgen
bereiten das ergebnis zur versprochenen
produktion in russland kam es nie und
tote spricht überhaupt niemand mehr über
dieses produkt ein paradebeispiel ist
auch der russische impfstoff gegen das
corona virus boden xv auf
dem papier funktioniert dämmstoff das
heißt an entwicklung verlief durchaus
erfolgreich die formel war korrekt ich
weiß nicht ob ihr euch noch daran
erinnert aber damals gab es eine
weltweite debatte über die wirksamkeit
des russischen stars doch heute redet
niemand mehr über ihnen er ist noch
nicht einmal von der whu zugelassen die
qualität der einzelnen vor allem aus
unterschiedlichen fabriken schwankte so
stark dass ich noch nicht einmal die
russen selbst das zeug spritzen wollten
und sie bekamen dieses problem nie unter
kontrolle wir haben damals übrigens auch
ein video darüber gedreht dass ich euch
verlinken werden womit er es also in der
russischen rüstungsindustrie zu tun
haben sind ganz viele fälle wie der von
sputniks wir reden hier von weltklasse
kampfjets die auf dem reißbrett als
prototyp und in kleinen stückzahlen
technologische wunderkinder sind dann
aber nicht die richtige munition
bekommen wir sprechen von hightech
panzern wie nicht in massenproduktion
hergestellt werden können weil es im
land keine zulieferer für kritische
bauteile gibt von präzisions raketen die
nicht so präzise sind wie sich zu sein
scheinen und so weiter und so fort im
grunde haben wir es mit lauter
gescheiterten projekt zu tun projekten
die für eine erfolgreiche kriegsführung
wichtig wären mit ihren scheitert also
auch der krieg dabei gelang es puhdys
motorrad jahre lang diese schwachstelle
zu verheimlichen aber jetzt wo wir die
wirksamkeit dieser waffen auf dem
schlachtfeld sehen erkennen wir dass
sich all unsere annahmen bezüglich der
leistungsfähigkeit der russischen
wirtschaft bewahrheitet haben überspitzt
ausgedrückt russland war nie mehr als
eine große tankstelle mit atomraketen es
bleibt also nur noch eine frage und ich
überlasse es bräuchte sie in den
kommentaren zu beantworten wie steht es
angesichts der geschilderten zustände
wohl um russlands nukleare streitkraft
wir alle wissen dass russland über das
größte atomwaffenarsenal der welt
verfügt putin hat sogar damit gedroht
ist einzusetzen wir wissen dass es sich
nur um billige einschüchterungsversuche
handelt da die doktrin so etwas gar
nicht zulässt und putin ganz genau weiß
dass er bohlen einsatz von atomwaffen
viel länger weiterregieren kann als mit
dem trotzdem wäre es eine durchaus
interessante und ergründen wertefrage
funktionieren seine atomwaffen wirklich
was wenn viel der sprengkraft für
unbrauchbar geworden sind diese müssen
regelmäßig erneuert werden da das darin
enthaltene radioaktive material dem
stecken sagt fall unterworfen ist sind
die russischen interkontinentalraketen
wirklich so effektiv wieder kreml
behauptet nun natürlich will dies keiner
wirklich auf die probe stellen und sich
auf diese art von russischen atom
roulette verlassen daher sind es vor
allem zwei dinge auf welche sich die
nato nun konzentriert um putins optional
zu entschärfen minuziöse aufklärung und
verteidigung so ermöglichen source
systeme die beobachtung des russischen
atom u boots sobald es auf seinem hafen
ausläuft wird es flog fordert us u boote
verfolgt ähnliche mechanismen existieren
von jedes ziele und jede mobile
abschluss einrichtungen schließlich hat
die ausgezeichnete fast lückenlose
aufklärungsarbeit der us und uk
geheimdienste in der ukraine gezeigt wie
hoffnungslos die russen auf diesem
gebiet mittlerweile unterlegen sind die
kombination all dieser faktoren lässt
das risiko erahnen dass russland im fall
eines nuklearen austauschen nicht in der
lage wäre auch nur einen bruchteil
seines arsenals erfolgreich einzusetzen
aber dies ist schon wieder ein thema für
ein eigenes video denn wie gesagt was
denkt ihr warum sollten die atomwaffen
eine ausnahme bilden und nicht unter den
gleichen problemen leiden wie der rest
des russischen waffenarsenals was sollte
die nato noch unternehmen um russland
weiter von aussen zu ende passen wie
immer sind auf eure beiträge schon sehr
gespannt und ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat ihr vielleicht auch
etwas gelernt haben falls ja geht es mit
einem like das mit eure freunde und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glück keines
unserer videos nicht so verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den link
dazu findet ihre beschreibung unter dem
video ich mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]